we're talking about the future of  ukraine and the future of the european  union and our democracies  and it is that history that is being  written as i speak  our destinies are linked ukraine is  a member of the european family putin's  aggression against ukraine is an  aggression an attack against all  the principles  that we hold dear it's an attack against  democracy  against  sovereignty of states  against the freedoms of a people to  choose its own destiny and shape its own  future  the way in which we respond today  to this odious attack by russia against  ukraine will determine  the future of ukraine and also the  future of our union  and  going beyond that even the future of the  entire european continent so let us  remain faithful to the principles that  have been our guiding principles and our  common responses to date  its responsibility  unity  solidarity and determination